[Music]
everybody I'm with Adobe I Oh quick show
of hands who hasn't heard of service
just a few who is a vegan or vegetarian
here I'll have to apologize in advance
because I'll be showing some some things
might be upsetting so my talk is about
Apache open whisk it's a service
platform also known as FAS which is
functions as a service forgive the corny
pun Who am I I'm part of the Adobe io
team and I'm a longtime PhoneGap in
Apache Cordova contributor you can find
me at twitter or email me directly if
you have questions after this so the
major server server providers i'm just
showcasing four of them here for my
presentations purposes are I like farms
right when you you provision a server is
like buying a whole cow at the end of
the month you get a new cow no matter
what so no matter what if you don't like
the steak or you don't even wanna meet
it's still still wasteful so where the
weather's function says the server's
coming so function says service
landscape right now consists of mainly
Amazon because they're bigger gherla
Microsoft Azure has your functions and
Google platform has their club functions
and at the top there you'll see two
to serverless platforms based on open
Wisc open with the logo on the right
Adobe IO and IBM cloud functions are
based on open risk here's the quick
table about what these serverless
platforms languages they cover as you
can see open Wisc supports the most but
it's an illusion because their market
share is not as big as Amazon so would
the one big thing about open risk is it
can support any compiled language such
as go or C or even rust in a docker
container and they can run it as you can
see here docker is in gray which is for
go so it's not a first-class support but
true a docker container Google only
scores note for now and as your only
supports a few this list is current as
of a few days ago so maybe Amazonas
supports something new there right so
what I'm talking about is sausages so
you don't care what where all the meat
comes from you care about a sausage
that's essentially what server list is
it's not a perfect metaphor but I work
with me so you pay money you get what
you want sausages you don't care about
other parts of the meat are wasted all
that waste becomes sausage so I mean
that's a metaphor I'm going for so as
you probably see how Amazon does lambda
Google does lambda but you don't know
how the sausage is made
I'm gonna go into a little bit of how
open waste works so a little bit of
trivia about open risk it was code named
Wisc from IBM research
but why whisk whisk is being moved
nimbly and quickly and the code runs
quickly and guest gets whisked away
that's essentially what surrealist says
in the open west context it runs a
docker container and it quickly goes
away and also it was chosen for an easy
three letter CLI and of course open
means open source and open risk so let's
see the what open waste is made of so as
you can see there's a lot of open source
technologies concerned that open risk
consists of nginx which in simple terms
is just a web server Kafka simple terms
message queue cache Libby as a database
and docker is a container the docker
container let me go back so you see the
top right there's that the golang mascot
and skaila people developers develop in
Scylla to implement a lot of
functionality and open whisk and the
goal part is the go CL the risk CLI is
implemented and go so if any of you are
proficient in any of these technologies
I welcome you to contribute to the open
source project so who are the
contributors to open whisk the biggest
four are of course IBM who who donated
project to Apache and the project is not
a top-level project yet but it's in
incubation and of course the Bilby who I
work for
and Red Hat and Samsung to a limited
part and a lot of other independent
consultants
so open within a nutshell let's describe
how it works
take for example an invent that comes in
so you see in the top left for example
from a device like a rain sensor the
invent source which is a rain sensor
we'll call a trigger the trigger is for
example it's called you know rain is
falling which is associated to a rule
which is a one-to-one mapping between a
trigger and a rule but each rule maps to
multiple actions so the action could be
logging rainfall for example and each
layer is designed to scale independently
and that's open within a nutshell
so what are the benefits of the open
whisk this is not just specific to open
waste but to functions and as a service
in general the first thing is to pay as
you go so you pay only for what you use
efficient use of resources for both for
you and the vendor elasticity auto
scaling you don't have to worry about
spinning more servers heterogeneous
development so your team can use
multiple languages and skill sets so you
don't have to get for example someone
that knows that certain language only
for example open with support swift so
if your team is heavy and iOS Swift they
can do service it's with an open risk
and one of the biggest things is
on-premise deployment and testing
offline
so you don't have to have it hosted by
Amazon you can host it in your own data
center and also one of the big things is
you can chain actions without extra
coding so you from inputs and outputs
for each action you can chain them
together through the command line to
link them without writing any extra code
you can chain actions for example if
action one does a video upload
input is some video data and output is a
URL the second action will get your URL
and it will output analysis for example
for machine learning learning and
finally the biggest thing that I care
about is it's open source and there's no
vendor lock-in there's a quick start of
how does you run open risk that's a QR
code if you want to go to it's not
particularly quick for you to run it but
uh so James Thomas from IBM wrote a blog
post how to run open ways quickly so
first you gotta install doctor and then
you run this make file and it will
install everything that you saw there
there I did I show you nginx Kafka and
everything so once you run it you use a
make file again to control it stop and
run so after you've done the open wisk
QuickStart you can run the open waste
workshop it's a simple npm install as
you can see it covers all the features
of open risk that will take you a few
hours which we don't have time to cover
today so i'm gonna show you how to
create an action quickly since i'm not
gonna be doing a demo so the open way
CLI is called wsk so it's a simple wrist
action create action name
that's your javascript file and update
and finally an invoke and invoke you
pass parameters to it and you receive
something back and standard out so that
just creates the action on your local
server but you want to expose it to the
web so how do you do that create a
package and you do to see the same
a method but you pass a path and some
some parameters and annotation web true
so and once you create that you press
get and - - URL and you'll get that URL
that is exposed to external users so
what's in an action file if you've done
C or Java you know there's a main
function that's called as the main part
of your program is the same in your
JavaScript for open risk so the main
main function takes prompt parameter
object and you can use that and when you
return from the web action the main
important part is the body and the
params also contain metadata for the
running task so if you're doing an
action file what about NPM packages if
you've done any aw slap in your it WS
lambda you'll you'll know that you npm
install your package with your action
code and you zip the whole folder up and
upload the zip instead of action j s
however for native code and PM packages
you have to npm install to a docker
container that's the same environment as
your server aslam runtime so they can it
can get the same same architecture
before you upload it and open waste as a
48 Meg upload limit but there's this
workarounds available that you can do
where you can package your NPM packages
in a docker container that your server
can reference so what you work around
that for you my limit so you've you've
defined all your actions and how do you
deploy it right so open with recently
helped contribute to a plugin to the
serverless framework Cerberus framework
is a not affiliated with open ways it's
an in-depth
project and it helps people abstract the
deployment to all the different server
list platforms I encourage you to check
it out so you can use that to deploy to
open whisk or lambda or a Google or zero
so final part I want to talk about it
maybe I'll run time WI writing time is
based on open whisk it's just like IBM
platform since it's based on open waste
like the way PhoneGap or ionic is based
on Apache Cordova like a browser has its
engine so I don't we have you run times
engine is open whisk it's built on open
waste and it uses the same tools it
helps our internal themes leverage
server lists to other functions within
the enterprise unless our customers and
devs extend and build interesting things
based on our data because we have a lot
of data adobe is known for their
creative products but we were also known
for our analytics and marketing cloud so
it's pre integrated with the way io
events an api gateway and you will have
the easy and your access to all adobe
api's if you go to Adobe that I you will
see all the API is available to all
users finally thank you thank you to
everyone for listening to the desktop
it's a quick server your own server list
thank you
[Applause]